this week evolved joins titanfall and
civilization beyond Earth on the list of
elite games to be featured in game spots
the next big game series and what pray
tell does that mean the next big game
not only focuses on games that will have
a big impact on the industry it also
highlights the developers that bring
these experiences to life so all this
week on gamespot you'll find interviews
with the team at Turtle Rock Studios and
video features that give you a glimpse
of what it's like to play each class of
hunter not to mention the monster if you
don't know why evolve is our next big
game then you haven't been paying
attention it's a four-on-one multiplayer
battle as four players try to combine
their class specific abilities to take
down the fifth player who is a giant
frickin monster Godzilla is a lot
scarier when you know there's a human
intelligence behind it and wreaking
havoc as an eldritch God is so much more
satisfying when you know you're
terrorizing your friends this is the
kind of game in which no match plays out
the same way and every match is a story
so take some time this week to check out
our next big game coverage of evolve and
see what we're all excited about
out of this
you